We said we want to decompose a to the following matrices.
P is going to contain the eigenvectors. So p is
the Matrix with eigenvectors.
as columns
D will be the Matrix.
containing
the eigenvalues for the eigenvectors and
P to the power negative 1 is
the inversion of the Matrix this minus
one business by the way has a very nice explanation and
it has to do with division. You see
we cannot we cannot perform division in linear algebra.
If you remember the axioms that we talked about. I think
we talked about the axioms of vectors not the axioms of matrices. But
anyway, the vision is not what you can do what you
can do have always multiply.
By the you know, one over the
value. So for example, if you have a scalar three to
cancel it out.
It can multiply it by 1 over 3.
So it basically if you have over three, you can represent it as
three to the power negative 1.
This is where the this is where the mind is one comes
from. So this should be minus 1.
We have just solved this.
We have also actually solved that we actually solve this before
we did that.
And this I'll show you how it's the I'll remind you how it's done again.
So I'm going to scroll all the way down.
So we will take these together stack them into a matrix and we'll get
the Matrix p
So that means that a will remain
what it is. That's a p will be
the eigenvectors V sub
1 V sub 2 first eigenvector second eigenvector and
then D will be the diagonal matrix containing
The eigenvalue so I'm going to set these all to 0 what
were the eigenvalues again?
One of them was yeah, the first argument value was one and
the second argue value was four. So this will become one.
and four